the last time i spoke to you it was uh
you were talking about yes i am glorious
perfume i still wear it
i always get compliments big fan
yeah love it so much um so i want to ask
you really quickly about doll face i was
watching the trailer for season two and
i couldn't stop laughing it looks so
good i know fans are excited for this
what was it like for you reuniting with
such a talented cast for season two it
was so nice and i mean especially coming
out of the well not coming up but while
in the pandemic for such a long time it
was so refreshing and you know we all
felt so fortunate and grateful to be
able to be shooting
in still sort of the unknown but to be
reunited after you know a few years so
it felt really good to be back but then
at the same time it also felt like we
picked up right where we left off like
we haven't missed a beat which is super
nice and just goes to show you how
genuine our friendship really is offset
so that was gonna be my next question
what's the vibe like on set with such
talented women
it is so funny we are
all very similar to our characters very
similar to our characters
so as you you know by saying that you
can tell how different we are all are
but the vibe on set is just really fun i
mean even when we come out of like what
we just did on a weekend like couldn't
be more different like kat and brenda
came and they like picked vegetables
from their garden and like you know
knitted the whole weekend meanwhile
esther and i have like some crazy story
about what we did
it's just so different and it's fun to
always be you know together
what was it like having your friend lily
sing on set because i am i'm not gonna
lie just like i cannot wait to see her
it is so fun a obviously we are both
canadians yeah we have a lot of
understanding amongst us um but she's
just so talented and it was sort of the
perfect fit um for my character to play
opposite of and it was just great you
know
stella has always been a very fluid
character and so i think having liv's
character be on there it wasn't really
like a huge to do
it just you know happened and then they
fell for each other and it was nice to
really portray that story that's so cool
well listen you're working on this show
with fantastic women in front of the
camera behind the camera you are the
head of these fantastic
businesses based on the you know you're
just surrounded by fantastic people
international women's day is right
around the corner what's it like
constantly working with such talented
women
it's amazing and it's invigorating and
it's what inspires me to do more and
feel like i'm capable of doing more
yeah um
yeah i don't know it's just so amazing
especially in this day and age to just
be surrounded around
so many incredible women
you know and i think we're just at such
a point where we're all rooting for each
other and there's just
so much of a pie as they like to say to
go around and you really feel that so
it's awesome to have now built this
community of other like-minded women um
to be able to learn from to be able to
pull inspiration from and just to get
some you know solid advice from at the
end of the day so having a community
with them is there's nothing better
yeah i love that um you know when you
are working on base you know i can only
imagine like when you're first putting
this together and launching this brand
it's turning four this year it's crazy
is is that wild
it's crazy it's insane that i get to do
what i've always dreamed of doing and
when you know i realized what that was
that i'd wanted to do which was exactly
what base is
um
i just it's it's a dream it's i feel
like some days i'm gonna wake up you
know to be able to get up and be able to
work with a small but mighty team
um is really awesome and to be able to
create products selfishly for myself at
first but then to also be able to see
other people enjoying them and then
popping up at the airport when i'm there
like there's nothing like it it's the
most exciting thing and yeah um i
absolutely love it that was my first
child fire
so yeah i'm i'm very proud of face and
what we've been able to do especially
throughout these past few years yeah
yeah exactly you know the past year has
been challenging on all businesses so to
know that you're still thriving is so
exciting um base pets i have a frenchie
i want one let me okay tell me black or
beige and we're sending it out
yay
but that's so cool you know it's wild
seeing how it's evolved would you say
that you know mother had also kind of
changed design and really uh influenced
your your design process yeah and
getting to work with other women that
were kind of in the same
sort of life experience that i was at
which was motherhood so i got to
trial and test out a bunch of products
prior to having atlas but then it came
in really handy when you know i loved
what we had created at base and then i
found so many other moms and dads also
got to enjoy what we created knowing
that it came from like so many different
trials of it now having that experience
that i can really speak from adds to it
as well but yeah um it's really fun pet
collection was also a no-brainer and i
think
what we were able to do best was pivot
quickly you know having such a small and
great team it allowed us to be a lot
more nimble so when we saw okay cool you
may not be able to get onto the plane
that's fine we don't need to just do
luggage
let's be the go-to on-the-go brand
instead of just being in people's minds
travel it was really great so yeah yeah
well
i know you like your face masks it's
always fun seeing you wear them on
social media uh have you ever thought
about expanding into skincare when it
comes to bass you know i say never say
never but i feel like for right now with
face and then also with onto hockey yeah
traveling and drinking and that makes
sense for me right now but hey i am a
big advocate of skincare but i also have
a lot of great friends that have their
lines that i use and absolutely love so
i don't know it always has to feel right
and genuine and i have to be excited
about it so when those three things kind
of come together then i know it's time
to maybe do something else but yeah
quite happy and quite busy with what i
currently have going on and i i don't
want to overextend myself so yeah right
now this is perfect
you are busy it's so impressive to see
your name attached to things in your
executive producing shows and you're
starring in shows and you have you know
obviously your businesses uh when it
comes to onda first of all do you know
when it's coming to canada honestly that
is like my biggest goal is to get to
canada there's a lot more rules and
regulations over there yeah we will be
getting it over there and i will be so
happy when that day happens because that
is like the number one question i get
asked the most on i want it to be there
just as badly so yeah later it will be
okay good that was check no that was
like the number one question i just
didn't want to ask at first um also you
did onto apparel which was really cool
was it like getting into that kind of
world it's fun you know we've kind of
like dipped our toes in with both honda
and with bass but i think we have such a
cool brand that i absolutely love just
even the logo of it and what it stands
for it's clearly able to bring that into
apparel as well and be able to wear it
you know proudly so
um yeah it's fun getting into the hats
and the merch of it all is is also
another sort of like fun avenue to play
around in
yeah you know it's really fun so many
people feel so invested in your life and
they love following you on social media
i mean when you when you see a number
like 32 million do you
you have so many followers on instagram
i mean it's like all of canada um
is that like do you think about that
when you're posting things or is it just
what you like i do and i don't i do
that you know milestone of like the 32
round number but then at other times
when i am posting i don't focus too much
on it
i then i probably would never post i'd
overthink every everything yeah i think
what you know
people who have followed sort of my
journey appreciate is the fact that i
kind of just put it out there and
and not so curated either like yes
but definitely my stories and now
getting into tick tock it's just fun and
i'm having fun with it i don't take
social media too seriously as i don't
think anybody really should and i think
that they appreciate seeing that side of
me
yeah oh absolutely and your videos on
youtube are so good
i know how busy you are but if you had
the opportunity to executive produce a
reality show
of your life would you be interested in
that oh my gosh
again i'd say never say never just
because i have so many funny moments and
so many great experiences that i get to
witness that i would at times love to be
like oh i wish there was a camera here
and that's why i you know i also started
shaycations was because i was feeling so
fortunate to be able to go to these
incredible places and meet amazing
people
so to be able to
to share that sort of
experience and differently is is really
what i would be open to doing so
yeah you never know you never know all
right i'm just you know your fans will
love it so i'm just throwing that out
there
um i also want to talk about the
cleaning lady uh an executive producer
on this so what was it about this
project i'm sure you've seen so many
scripts that you really wanted to put
your name on
this was an adaptation from an
argentinian show that i fell in love
with and i had watched a whole season of
it and i was like this is amazing you
know it would be fun to kind of switched
up and
add different characters to it and bring
it here and that's exactly what we did
so partnering with warner brothers and
then with fox to be able to do it was
super cool and it was something i hadn't
done before either but i mean that sort
of challenge of wearing a new hat
doesn't scare me really anymore it's
exciting i think again when you get out
of your comfort zone is when you really
grow and if i mess up then whatever then
i just
pick myself up and learn from it like
what's the worst that can happen at the
end of the day and i feel that with all
aspects of my life so with then
executive producing this show it was
something that i found entertaining and
i wanted to put my own spin on it and
that's exactly what we did and you know
people are enjoying it and to be able to
see my name in a different role
is also really exciting
um was there anybody that really you
drew inspiration from in terms of not
only getting into the acting world but
then transitioning as an executive
producer and then of course launching so
many brands like is there is there a
couple of people that you really look up
to
honestly to begin with it was you know
jessica simpson i think seeing what she
did was starting her brand and her phone
and all of that was really inspiring
then follow jessica's album
you know now looking at producers reese
witherspoon does incredible productions
and all of that so i feel like
it's
you know women like that and being able
to see them do it all
again allows me to feel like i can do it
too and it's kind of cool to have them
as you know great examples of that